[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
couple que pour la première du travail javi et
Deena's oh la première fois seeker
America délivre vraiment votre Javad
escalade Dali Museum
Oh fortune Aqaba vamo voir Camille Ishod
voici vos deux visières pour le mettre dans un
gène Cell vivo  vous pur
oui yuccas Pas d'
école Aseema
litleo VLF il y a 125 ans universel et j'ai
pris un gros risque sur un film qui ne portait pas
simplement sur les dinosaures c'était un film
qui embrassait la question séculaire si la
science-fiction devenait des éventualités scientifiques la
règle vestimentaire était un
la célébration de quelque chose que nous avons tous
aimé ce film est différent
ce film pousse quelque chose que nous
savons vers l'avenir vous avez
tout ce dont vous avez besoin dans un
film jurassique mais ensuite il devient plus
claustrophobe il a ce genre d'
élément gothique et vous commencez à  créer
la tension d'une manière très différente
nous choisissons le film quelques années
après les événements de Jurassic world je
sais pourquoi nous sommes ici
un sauvetage de quiconque sauve les dinosaures
fr  om l'île qui est sur le point d'exploser
ce qui pourrait se passer viens avec moi tu sais que
tu ne peux pas rester ici
emballe ton homme en ce moment c'est là que
nous avons réalisé que ce ne sont pas de bonnes
personnes qui s'occupaient de la première
partie de ce film est en plastique  Jurassic
et ensuite vous entrez dans ce monde beaucoup plus
dangereux, nous sommes arrivés dans ce
manoir où ils vendent
ces animaux aux enchères au plus offrant,
ils en ont fait l'Indo Raptor,
ils vont les vendre pas bleus, ils en ont
besoin pour autre chose que nous obtenons  pour en
savoir beaucoup plus sur Owen et sa
connexion très spéciale avec le bleu, il a
porté un toast dans ce bâtiment, je pense que le
cœur des histoires sur boo hey girl,
j'ai dit que nous fermons tout cela,
nous espérons que les gens sortiront avec leur
imagination élargie de  quel
film de Jurassic Park peut être ces créatures étaient
ici avant nous et si nous ne faisons pas attention,
elles vont battre là-bas après la bienvenue
dans Jurassic world
[Musique]
vous